he was  mad at me  for taking the job with james franco he  hated james franco and was  already accusing me  of kind of secretly having a thing with  him in my past since we had done  pineapple express together it went from  asking me about how my kissing scene  went or how the sex scene went to asking  me what james franco had done in the  scene he was saying  really disgusting things about my body  about how i liked it just straight up  taunting me he called me a go-getter he  called me a [ __ ] and i slowly get up and  move to the front of the plane and he  starts throwing things at me because i'm  not answering him i was looking out of  the window and he slaps my face my back  has turned to him and i feel this boot  in my back it just kicked me in the back  i thought to myself i don't know what to  do i can't believe he just did he just  kicked me